welcome to this video playing the Jedi
its Jedi right the pronunciation and I
haven't seen the movie yet force awakens
and pretty curious though okay i had
this line i have to though i do
something else now the line that I've
played down I lost a couple of times
recently and I don't want to repeat that
without any kind of improvement Wow and
it's early Queen a five
queen is yeah not very well placed
thereon 185 so he puts it on age five
where it is also not very well placed
but okay let's see I was trying for
group to e5 and he prevented that yeah i
was thinking 94th even an idea but ok
let's push that push that Bishop back
think you will go 26 and it would fit
fit the earlier play it isn't isn't good
at all but it fits what he did earlier
we should almost never belongs on d6 in
this kind of situation here we gauge for
as an idea and so was my idea behind you
ruger behind I deform I get this rook
let going
so H for Queen g6 can also start with
Bishop g5 p.m. hmm can just about who
would it maybe this is good threatening
it threatens just who gauge for okay
it looks dangerous for black it really
does so something I'm think direct or
something subtle here we should see for
getting this in books e1 threads Bishop
c4 winning the Queen and okay if you
insist I'll take your queen always said
the princess he has that princess
princess leia or I'm taking the Queen
okay black resigns yep yeah it i think
it already was dangerous first that was
a that was a bit dicey yeah it's not
clear that the queen is good on a five
very early commitment of that piece i
have my doubts about bishop t6 it just
belongs on e 74 up to eight normally but
okay but it's not like black losses or
so it's just that I like white look here
and now it already gets interesting yeah
this is an interesting move trying for
this is this but I didn't really see
something super conclusive if even if he
goes have six I didn't see anything so
clear and this this 23 f 50 i am taking
the rook there okay that line isn't a
big deal big problem but he can go there
yeah so it doesn't felt didn't feel some
convincing this is why i went here and
this is now getting dangerous he has to
play a pawn move h6 when you went at
five but I expected h6 or g6 and both
are definitely tricky to play
age 6 well but the line that the engine
is giving I very likely wouldn't have
even considered Quincy to me it makes
lots of sense trying to again put
pressure on that Queen position but this
is a very weird line or graph for now
okay the roof doesn't have any other
squares now I'm better but very
difficult to play yeah this was just it
looks useful and it has a one move
threat which ignored so that was the end
of this game okay thanks for watching